[Music]
hello YouTube just Louis in my friends
this is grunge in here
welcome to my third episode of killer
mini chest traps in this episode we are
going to look at three wonderful mini
opening chest wraps and the content are
as follow
you
the first trap occurred in the elephant
gambit which arises after the following
order efore 'if i Knight to f3 and now
defy here white has two choices but we
are looking at the second most popular
choice by white namely Knight captures
ePHI and after we play d captures e4
White has this lethal attacking move
Bishop to c4 which straight away put the
question mark to the black camp well if
you really like the shilling gambit then
this is the upgrade version as the idea
and the concepts are very much similar
and here black plays this super tactical
boom Queen to G Phi inviting white to do
your vast on the Epps Evan let's check
out what is going to happen if white
captured on f7 the first option is very
natural Knight captures f7 attacking two
major guys but in fact it's a big time
blunder and I hope you indeed know the
refutation yup
the first boy is Queen captures g2
counter attacking the white rook and
after rook to a fun black has this star
move Bishop to g4 and that poor Queen is
trapped there and to rescue her why it
has to either play the move after E or
the move Bishop to e2 in either case he
is going to lose the game
instantly well Bishop to e2 is a pretty
bad move the simple reason is the
support on f7 has been gone and now the
simple transaction Bishop takes Queen
takes and now King captures f7 and black
emerged with a clear piece advantage
okay what happens instead of Bishop to
e2 white played the move f3
this is even worse guys as after Bishop
captures after he rope captures f3 and
now the winning blue pawn captures f3
and white doesn't have time to capture
the rook in the corner as after the
simple continuation have to check King
to e2 and now double discover check
which allows black to choose between
taking the queen or checkmating the
white in 3 moves with Queen to g5
so if your opponent goes for the night
captors f7 then game can be finished
very quickly probably the best move in
this position is Bishop captures f7 but
still I want to show you a high profile
trap in this line as after King to e7
Black is attacking to piece so white
responds his force White has to play d4
attacking our Queen and more or less we
continue with the same team yup Queen
captures g2 Brooke to have fun and this
time around
Bishop to h3 threatening the room and
white can't play Queen to me to as black
is indeed going to take on have fun that
means what has the only response in this
position Bishop to c4 saving the rogue
and now black play this very cunning
move Knight to d7 trying to disclose the
night on the if I Square this position
has been occurred few times in the
database and here y can play any other
moves except my to f7 which looks more
natural as now White has saved his rook
on f1 why not go for the grabbing the
rook in the corner and becoming a piece
up well that's natural response but in
fact as a disaster zone as after blacks
next reply night to b6
the Seaforth Bishop is an overloaded
piece as he has to defend to baby's hand
now by force he has to give up one of
them the best what can do over here is
Queen to e2 supporting the bishop but
after the following continuation night
capture c4 queen capture seafood yes
indeed now queen is defending both the
piece but it's a different story as
black and now captured the rook on f1
square and after Queen takes bishop
takes if why take over Bishop then King
takes f7 and black image with a piece of
so accordingly White has to go for the
rook hunt with Knight captures a cheat
and when black save his Bishop with
Bishop to g2 for a time being yes if you
count the material it is equal but look
at the poor knight stuck in the corner
as he's not going to see a daylight and
after some simple moves black will again
emerged with a piece advantage so these
are some of the wonderful many traps
exist in the elephant gambit in Knight
captures ePHI line
the second mini trap is one of my
favorite as currently I'm trying the
English defense regularly and I must
tell you there are players up til 2200
fall for this trap
the English defense arises after the
falling water d4 e 6c for b6 Knight to
c3 Bishop to b7 and now as for the
theory the most popular choice is evil
white grabbing every single space in the
center of the board and accordingly
black tried to attack this fragile
center with Bishop to b4 threatening in
for so wide responses very obvious
Bishop to d3 supporting the e4 but now
comes the star mu which sets up a
cunning trap and Bacchus f5 so once
again black has renewed the threat on e4
and if your opponent continue here with
either the move D Phi or f3 then you can
always take on e4 and followed by Knight
to f6 which always gives black a very
comfortable game so in many games white
has done this blunder namely he captures
f5 thinking that black has made an error
and now I'm going to expose black King
but in fact now it is white who is
losing on the spot as if you remember my
Makino Huskie gambit video yup Bishop
captures g2 and no matter however why
triggers his rook is going to hunt down
in near future
ok let's look at the most critical line
Queen to h5 Jack and the key team you
have to remember is once your Bishop is
out the king has this wonderful safe
Square King to f8 and even though black
position looks somewhat shaky believe me
this is a completely
safe and winning position for the black
camp in fact in the database there are
two international masters fall for this
trap so you can see the potential of
this line now to illustrate how easy
black game is I like to show you one of
my quickest win against a 2,200 where my
opponent continued with pawn takes c6
threatening a checkmate and once again
the key move in this position is Quint
we ate not only attacking a six but
threatening Queen exchange which is also
not desirable for the white camp okay my
opponent continued with this green check
and I simply respond with Knight to f6
and now you see the danger as white is
definitely going to be pissed down very
soon well in the game he tried Knight to
e2 and after Bishop captures h1 he
responded with Bishop to g5 he really
want to quickly castle on the Queen side
and expose my king but in reality he
doesn't have time for all this I simply
respond with Queen captures e6 again
trying to exchange the Queen and obvious
enough my opponent decline with Queen to
f4 okay now it's placton to cash in so
Bishop capture c3 taking advantage of
the pin Knight White has to take with
the phone and after that the winning
move of the game
Bishop to e4 which turn out to be too
strong for the white camp well he tried
Bishop captures f6 but this is all been
calculated as after Bishop captures d3
yes White has this wonderful bishop
which is threatening a discover check
but is there any threat from the white
the answer is nope
he tried Bishop to e5 but after Queen to
f7 Bishop captures e7 I simply exchange
the Queen and then take on c4
and at this point my opponent count the
material and he realized that he is a
rope down for obviously no compensation
so he resigned again
you
the third and the final minute trap
happened against the Dutch defense which
arises after the Mordor d4f I and now
this very cunning new ash tree planning
to play g4 well I have tried to slime
few times online and what I observed
that many Dutch players are not very
well prepared against it
for example the most obvious move Knight
to f6 can be responded with g4 and if
black now declined this gambit with
either mu E 6 or D Phi then the space
white keen on the kingside is a deciding
factor in upcoming middle game so let's
see what happens after black take this
campus with point x g4 h takes g4 and
now Knight takes d4 ok White's big idea
is he wants to play Queen to d3
attacking on at 7 and funny enough black
has the only response namely g6 but
again if you check this position in
online database you will find out that
Knight to f6 has been tried many times
even by 2300 rated opponent thinking
that they have covered all the bases but
what the missed out is this killer blow
boom
so there are two ways black and captured
the rook and in both the case his King
is going to be checkmated so that's not
an option
and when black make a space for his King
let's say e 6 then white can come in
with Queen to g6 check King to e7 and
now simply taking the rook on h8 and
with a piece of black has misplaced King
it is just a matter of time with a quick
victory for the white camp
I like to also point out dead after the
Muji six black is not out of the trouble
as after the simple continuation Bishop
to g5 defy and Knight to c3 black and
never played the move Bishop to g7
because of the simple tactic and this
you have to know yup rook captures at
seven and after rook takes at seven and
the Moon Queen captures g6 at the end of
the sequence not only white emerge with
an extra pawn but blacks open King
literally asked for the trouble zone in
the upcoming Miss game so this is one of
the wonderful attacking line against -
defense which also contains some nasty
traps that's it guys I hope you enjoy
and learn this wonderful mini trap
lecture feel free to like subscribe and
comment on my video and in future I will
come up with more till then
bye and take care